today marks three months since i banned
bobo from the show for considering
leaving the whack pack if you remember
bobo said he was going to leave the
whack pack and i told him he had to get
out yeah he didn't want it anymore so i
gave him a punishment of uh three months
off the air he left the voicemail hey
dog you know what's going on with me um
getting back on the air tomorrow because
tuesday would be three months as you
guys know
you know i dismiss you know jumping in
on things or topics and stuff like that
not only coming up with my own material
but this you know just something
breaking that i i'm not be able to jump
in on you know so that's why i just want
to know what's going on with that well
we should just make sure
he gets to jump in
yeah well for those of you who miss bobo
and who are you
i want to know who you are
marianne what do you think you've been
working with bobo uh is it time for his
band to be over i believe it is i think
he's it's absolutely time because i
don't think i could go another minute
with him texting me every day to see
wednesday and i said to him today's the
day so let's hear bobo have it and keep
me on the line well marianne has been
working with bobo to make him a better
caller she even she was very tough with
him i was impressed
what does that mean he practiced with uh
marianne oh yeah the day that he get
back on the year so he'll be a better
caller and i can play you some of this
we recorded it this is marianne actually
working with bobo in a very serious
manner what i want to ask is howard had
mentioned on the air about a documentary
with scott shannon he even asked robin
hey did you watch it wait wait wait do
we have a phone click
get to the [ __ ] question oh no i'm
telling the backdrop of how i i was
gonna want to hear that don't you know
what it takes to be a good caller get to
the point you might ask me how did you
come up with that so i'm gonna give you
the backdrop what's the [ __ ] question
all right let me just stuff in the top
let me just make believe we start over
all right i didn't know that you created
the howard 100 channels based on scott
shannon z100 which was the center of the
dial this way you're in the middle of
all the channels that's serious so
that's how he came about for channel 100
101. i never knew that it was based on
scott shannon
i don't know i thought the channel 100
was like because it was like the
greatest thing howard 100. i never heard
that all right okay so let's tighten it
up how it how'd you come up with howard
100 simple to the point yeah okay so i
think that's a good question then wow
these are some critiques
yeah what do you think howard i'm like
mickey goldman from sylvester stallone
the rocky movie you're a hundred percent
on the money so you know bobo has a
habit of it he's going let me give you
the backdrop the backdrop let me let me
give it the bag to wob
howard 100 is at the middle of the doyle
putting you in the center i would like
to be on channel 0 because i'm a nobody
uh here's another thing marianne worked
with bobo on before i put him on
bobo has a habit of asking about things
i've already covered on the show and
marianne called him out on it and i like
this listen carefully what would you
consider to be a trait from your dad
that you're most thankful for don't we
both listen to the same show haven't we
gone down that road before though i mean
i haven't with this maybe someone else
but then you can start saying well a lot
of people call up but why i said that
years ago i hear it all the time
questions i've said can you come up with
something that's a little more
pertaining to 2022. i'm trying to come
up with something um
i'll tell you what i observed on this
anyway none of bobo's questions were up
to marianne's standards
comes to your house as a dinner guest
it gets to the point of the evening
where it gets kind of late do you leave
a guest like paul mccartney downstairs
was it a certain pecking order like how
does this work is it is that's what i
want to know if there's a pecking order
do you excuse yourself or why what do
you mean a pecking order where do you
get this [ __ ] from see this is the
problem with you you think that
everybody's in a pecking order guess
what we're all created equal does
marianne really believe we're all
created equal have to talk
she's a saint at one point in this
conversation when bobo was practicing
for his return to the show
testing once
yes he tried to pitch a segment for the
show
and marianne was having none of it will
it be possible if your crack staff of 50
all right could bring back friday happy
hour that's not a question the people
fans would love it do it every friday
and then go back on monday and then play
the outtakes of it i think it'd be great
what do you think
i think it's [ __ ] what are you doing
writing or do you do the crack stamp for
50 now you're the crack staff of 51 and
you're [ __ ] writing content well i'm
just thinking bobo that was during
colvin been there done that listen bobo
doesn't always ask bad questions bubble
has generated some good questions over
the years granted
average how many once in a while bobo
does hit the home run and now ladies and
gentlemen mary anne i'm going to give
him his moment thank you for coaching
him yes thank you good luck barbara
break a leg remember what i said no
listening and no stupid quagmire word
i'm counting on you bobo thanks howard
love you all i need all right here we go
after lots of coaching and three months
of preparation
for his dynamic return to radio
[Music]
here's bobo
all right bobo you're on in florida hey
now yeah i have this question that i
crafted and uh how this pertains to you
all right not every photographer right
can draw it all but you have mastered
this really well
so would i be correct in saying that
your love of photography has helped you
elevate it and becoming an accomplished
dog
who could take pictures can draw but you
can do that oh that's what he said that
word was draw i was like what did he
just say howard can do something but i
don't know
topography
photographer
well bobo i don't know i mean i think
that's good
it's good to have you back and uh listen
uh
i'm sure there were people out there who
missed you and now you're back on okay
you had your punishment
i mean i felt like a fish out of water i
mean it has been three months
all right right and you know yeah i have
a life i do other stuff but i'm just
saying i love the show so much and i
like to jump in on things that i hear
you know or just come up with my own
stuff okay bobo welcome back bobo puppet
do you have anything to say i have one
more question howard if paul mccartney
was to come over for dinner
do you tell him
how shitty my questions are your
thoughts